I didn't try exy until the '90s and I
was actually was in San Francisco I'm
not going to say what I was doing but I
was doing a movie in San Francisco and
somebody said oh you got to try this
it's called X because that all the pills
were marked with an EG right and um so I
went sure I'll try that and honest to
God it was like the best best feeling
ever and you can't ever get that feeling
back well it's not just that I did get
it back a few times in San Francisco
but you feel like for a few days no
geez you are like like nothing phases
this guy no I except kidney stones
kidney stones got me this week yeah
stuff like that gets me like oh man
but what what what is kidney I heard
kidney stones is like as bad as
pregnancy I would never insult a Woman
by saying it it must be what it's like
to give birth but it's what it must be
like to give birth